Dinosaurier, Dinosaurier, Schwabblegund haut wie ein Anus.
Dinosaurier, dinosaurier, warum trägst du ein Tupit, Thürerlos? Ist eure Adresse. Hallo. Hallo und herzlich willkommen zur neuen paläontologischen Folge, das das Podcast-Sofor-Podcast-Projekt, Paläontologie-Projekt, mit dabei auch Prof. Dr. Flontien Will. Vielen, vielen Dank und natürlich auch herzlichen Dank an die Schaufel dieser Folge, die das Erdreich erstmal geöffnet hat, damit wir dort reinstechen können. Und zwar Ise hat, zeichnet verantwortlich für dieses fantastische Intro. Vielen, vielen Dank. Ja, vielen Dank an Ise und jetzt gilt es quasi erstmal den Pinsel in die Hand zuhmen und die Wahrheit ans Licht zu pinseln. Ja, alles wird weggepinselt. Alles, was nicht die Wahrheit ist, wird weggepinselt. Oder was nicht so fest, was zwar Teil der Wahrheit ist, aber nicht so fest am Knochen, dass es mit abgepinselt wird. Da besprechen, Herr Kollegus, denn ich würde sagen, die Wahrheit ist fest, die Wahrheit ist stabil und alles, was flüchtig ist, ist nicht die Wahrheit. Aber müssen wir nicht vorsichtiger sein vielleicht, weil die Wahrheit, die wir da hervorpinseln, ist vielleicht ein bisschen zu unangenehm. Vielleicht muss man ein bisschen vorsichtiger sein, weil hilft hier und da ja so ein bisschen mehr Dreck am Knochen, um nicht die ganze Wahrheit hervorzuspülen. Nun, da sprechen Sie typisch für Ihren Institut, wenn ich das so sagen darf, aber in unserem Institut wird das natürlich anders gehandhabt. Da ist die Priorität eins natürlich immer die ungeschönte Wahrheit. Und damit müssen wir uns eben auch mit dem Flip-Flop-Dinosaurier dann abfinden, so ist das nun mal. Ja, aber ich würde halt behaupten, dass sie vielleicht ist ihnen da ein Flip-Flop reingefallen. Vielleicht ist ihr da, weil ich weiß ja wie, ich habe ja ein paar Kollegen, eine Kollegin aus ihrem Institut, und wie die gearbeitet haben, teilweise an manchen Ausrahmungsstätten, gut, möchte ich jetzt hier in das Detail gehen, bin ich wieder der große Nestbeschmutzer, dann heisst es wieder in dem Paläutologie-Magazin Nestbeschmutzer Tietze, Stefan Nestbeschmutze. Und da habe ich keine Lust drauf, wir können ausgraben, wir können keine Wortspiele, das ist mir dann nochmal aufgefallen. Und ja, vielleicht ist Ihnen da einfach ein Flipflop in die Ausgrabungsstätte gefallen. Na gut, aber Herr Herr Dietze, Sie müssen zugeben, dass doch mittlerweile ausreichend bewiesen ist, dass der Triceratops sich fast ausschließlich von Zimtschnecken ernährt hat. Also das ist doch mittlerweile klar. Diese ganze Fleischfresser-Theorie, du hast doch lange überholt. Ne, das stimmt, da habe ich ja selber auch mitgeholfen an diesem bisschen... Herrliche Gebacken selber auch für die Veranstaltung, vielen Dank dafür. Ja, gern. Ich weiß nicht, ob Sie aufgefallen sind, aber so in kleiner Dinoform, also das Zimt war dann so quasi. Das war gar nicht aufgefallen. Ah ja, okay. Weil Sie sehr häufig davor stand, also weil Sie quasi nur davor stand. Ich habe Sie gar nicht im Tagungsraum gesehen. Ne, wahrscheinlich sah das so aus, bevor Sie gebackt haben, aber dann natürlich, dann bläht sich das so ein bisschen auf, wie sich ja viele von den Kollegen aufgebläht haben, wenn ich das so sagen darf, in den letzten Jahren, in denen ja nicht mehr allzu viele Feldversuche stattfanden, sondern man sich hauptsächlich in der Institutkantine aufgehalten hat. Aber das ist ein anderes Thema an der Stelle. Ja, ich höre dir wirklich nicht hin. Da können Sie auch mal vielleicht den Fitnesskurs, der angeboten wird von der Fakultät, vielleicht auch häufiger frequentieren. Das wäre doch mal ganz nett. Naja, jedenfalls haben wir herausgefunden, dass der Triceratops vor allem, Triceratops sagt man ja auch, vor allem Backwaren vollgezwungen hat, warme, gut riechende Backwaren. Warme Plunderwaren, hauptsächlich Plunder und alles, was eine Strudelform hatte, das hat er gerne genascht. Er hat auch nichts zu Bruder zu können, hat er nicht Nein gesagt, hat er nicht Nein geschrien. Weil wir haben ja auch seine Stimme nachkonstruiert, weil wir seine Sprechknochen gefunden haben. Genau. Ich kann es kurz mal hervorholen. Mhh, lecker! Mhh, lecker! Und vor allem die drei Hörner, wo wir ursprünglich davon ausgegangen sind, dass sie eigentlich als Waffe genieht haben. Nein, sie waren nur als Aufbewahrungsort für diese sehr naschigen Donuts möglich. Und das habe ich jetzt noch herausgefunden, es ist noch nicht erschienen, deswegen können Sie es noch nicht wissen, aber man konnte verschiedene Aufsätze drauf machen. Also man konnte den Rühr, den Knet und den Schneebesenaufsatz drauf packen. Den Quirl. Eine andere Theorie natürlich auch, dass man da mit schönen Marshmallows über dem Feuer zubereiten konnte, mit so einem schönen Horn, das konnte allerdings noch nicht bewiesen werden. Ich puste noch einmal kurz rein. Hm, leckercker! Also, da merkt man schon, es war ein sehr genüssliches Tier. Der Triceratops hat gerne geschlemmt. Ja, und beim Stegadon übrigens, der war komplett falsch rum. Also was wir dachten, ist der Schwanz ist eigentlich der Kopf und was wir dachten, ist der Kopf ist eigentlich der Schwanz. Bauch ist der Rücken, also alles war einmal falsch. Der Schwanz ist immer hoch in der Luft, der Kopf war immer ganz tief am Boden. Wir dachten sonst immer, der Kopf ist ganz hoch und der Schwanz zieht am Boden nach. Falsch. Der Kopf wird hinterhergezogen. Der Kopf wird unangenehm über den Boden gezogen. Der Kopf schlängelt sich wie eine Schlange voran und der Schwanz ist ganz hoch oben in der Luft, so als Abnehmer für das Stromleitsystem. Genau, Stromableiter. Stromableiter, Blitzerableiter. Natürlich für Lebewesen ab einer gewissen Größe natürlich auch ein Problem. Nicht trivial. Nicht trivial, einfach Blitz getroffen werden. In der Natur haben sich die mit Blitzerbleiter durchgesetzt, die mit so kleinen oben Metallvorrichtungen. Ja, ein bisschen doof, wenn er dann gerannt ist, immer Äste ins Gesicht geschlagen. Aber klar, schwierig, muss der ja immer klarkommen. Faszinierende Tiere. Schade, dass niemand mehr ins Museum kommt, oder? Schade, dass niemand mehr unsere Ausstellung sehen will. Gerade nur zu den Schmetterling wollen. Ich war jetzt in einer Ausstellung, die hieß Chicken. Ich muss jetzt mal echt bleiben. Also hier kann ich dir das Poster zeigen. Chicken. Erbe der Dinosaurier. Wo war die? Die war in Zürich. War eine ganz ganz kleine Ausstellung, es war nur ein Raum, wirklich. Also das Poster sagt, wir haben hier neue Erkenntnisse, kommt vorbei, langsam ist alles vorbei, alles ist erlaubt, es ist eh schon alles egal, sagt das Poster, aber es war nur ein einziger Raum, wo sehr viele Hühner waren und Hühnerskelette und es ist echt erschreckend, dass ein Hühnerskelett eins zu eins aussieht wie so manche Dinoskelette, die gefunden wurden, wo wir behaupten, es waren coole Echsenwesen, aber das ist eins zu eins von unserem Huhn. Ja. Das Skelett, Huhn, auch unkult, unkultster Vogel, Chicken, Huhn, Chicken, Huhn, in allen Sprachen, auch Chicken ist ja weird, Chicken, Huhn. Chicken kannst du nicht ernst nehmen, einfach alles da rein. Ich habe tatsächlich vor einer Zeit ein Referat gehalten über den Huhn, über das Onagadori-Huhn, eine japanische Zierrasse, die bis zu 22 Meter langen Schwanz haben kann.
Ein Riesenhuhn?
Nee, das Huhn selber ist recht klein, aber es hat einen wahnsinnig langen Schwanz, Onagadori.
Und das kommt daher, dass es ein bestimmtes Gen hat, das dafür sorgt, dass es sich nicht mausert.
Normalerweise mausern sich Hühner nämlich, das heißt sie werfen ihr Gefieder ab und dann wächst neues.
Und dieses Huhn tut das nicht.
Und deswegen wachsen die unendlich lange weiter und werden lächerlich lang.
Könnt ihr gerne mal googeln, gibt es tolle Fotos, Onagadori, Onagadori, Onagadori Huhn, ja sehr schön, das verstehe ich schon und dann gibt es wahrscheinlich Wettbewerbe, wer den langsten Schwanz gezüchtet. Ja genau, weil es ist natürlich super aufwendig, muss man sehr schwer in der Haltung, man muss den irgendwie sauber halten und so und super nervig auch einfach.
Und dann die anderen Hühner treten da immer drauf und und dann machen da Knoten rein. Das ist mir so klar. Schreckliches Sinn. Dass die anderen Hühner dann drauf treten, so als wäre es okay. Ja, die fahren halt, versuchen da immer mitzufahren. Die versuchen, die dann so trittbrettmäßig da so draufzustellen und da mitzufahren, während das andere Huhn da vorantrabt. Und dann denken sie, glaubt ihr, ich merke das nicht. Wenn du so ein Tandem hast, ich weiß nicht, ob du das kennst, aber wenn du mit dem Tandem durch die Stadt fährst und dann springen Leute immer hinten drauf. Immer hast du hier immer hinten drauf sitzen. Du siehst die ja auch selber nicht. Du kannst ja nicht im Strasseverkehr die ganze Zeit umdrehen und sagen, was machen Sie denn da auf meinem Tandem, runter da! Ja, das ist auch mein großes Problem, weil ich immer mit so einem Fahrrad, wo hinten dran noch so ein Anhänger dran ist, rumfahre. Und dann guckt man sich um und dann sitzen wieder zwei Leute, da sind wir Familie drin. Hast du eine Familie drin? Ja, ich bin ja weitestens unterwegs mit einem Bierbike, 16 Mann, war ich alleine da unterwegs. Und dann plötzlich schaust du dich einmal um, sitzen da acht Leute da, schönes Pilz in der Hand. Und dann denkst du, Leute, was ist das denn hier, die treten nicht mehr mit. Vor allem, dass du ganz nach rechts geguckt, weil du auf den Straßenverkehr geachtet hast. Und dann guckst du immer nach hinten, was für den Familien drin hängen. Zack, einmal an der Ampel stehen geblieben, dann kommen sie an. Was heißt Onagadori? Langschwanzhuhn. Einfach die Übersetzung, Langschwanzhuhn heißt das. Okay. Kann man das flechten, kann man den Schwanz flechten? Nee. Kann man nicht flechten? Kann man nichts mitmachen, außer ... Nö, aber Mauser ist interessant. Ich weiß, meine Welt sieht ich immer noch immer in der Mauser. Weil es gibt verschiedene Arten von Mauser, also die werfen dann die Federn ab und es gibt manche Vögel, die mausern sich so stark, dass sie eine Zeit lang gar nicht fliegen können, weil sie keine Federn mehr haben. Andere, die haben dann so ein rotierendes System, dass sie immer manche Federn abwerfen und die anderen behalten, sodass sie noch fliegen können das ganze Jahr. Manche sagen aber auch, weg damit und hauen dann alles weg und machen dann Pause, einfach mal Urlaub. Machen wir ja meistens zwei Wochen Urlaub. Hat Doofald-Benz in Airborne passiert quasi. Das ist natürlich schwierig, ja. In der Flugzeit, wenn du dann dich doll schüttelst und alles abwirfst. Aber wir können ja auch schon gleich die Top drei der Mauser aufmachen. Ja. Auf Platz eins bei mir werden nämlich direkt die Schockmauser, die nämlich als Verteidigungsmechanismus funktioniert, denn so manches Huhn hat keine bessere Idee, sich zu verteidigen, als im Notfall Federn abzuwerfen. Das heißt, ist euch vielleicht mal aufgefallen, wenn ihr mal so einen Huhn packt und hochhebt, fallen Federn ab, weil das in der Stresssituation einfach Federn abwirft, weil es keine bessere Idee hat. Das ist die beste Idee.
Also die kam zusammen eines Tages.
Das ist die beste Idee, die du gerade hattest.
Leute, wir brauchen irgendeine Idee.
Wir werden hier gerissen von Wölfen, von Hunden.
Hat jemand eine Idee?
Shoot, alles geht.
Wir sind das Nummer eins Opfer in allen Märchen.
Möchte ich das nochmal sagen?
Absolut.
Der böse Wolf kommt, der böse Hund kommt.
Kentucky Fried Chicken, Huhn weg.
So, haben wir Ideen, irgendwas, keine schlechten Ideen, alles geht.
Laseraugen.
Ja, wie soll das gehen?
Weiß ich nicht, du hast wirklich keine schlechten Ideen.
Okay, gut, fast keine schlechten Ideen.
Sonst noch Ideen, ich meine, wir haben Schnäbel, hat jemand eine Idee zu schnäbeln?
Hallo, meine Idee wäre mit meinem grossen...
Gustavo, schön, dass du da bist.
Nein, nein, nein, nicht Gustavo. Aber gut, wir lassen mal den japanischen Akzent jetzt weg. Ich hau den mit meinem großen Schwanz ein paar japanischen. Ja, du hast den langen Schwanz, du kannst fesseln, danke. Aber jetzt geht es mal um normale Hühner. Hat irgendjemand eine Idee? Okay, danke schön. Ihr habt nicht so lange Schwänze. Nein. Nee, sag du es mal einmal. Ja, letzte Reihe. Ich weiß, es ist das einzige, was wir haben, aber wir könnten Federn abwerfen. Da lachen doch die Hühner, was können wir denn damit erreichen, die Federn abzuwerfen? Naja, kurzer Verwirrungsmoment. Es könnte kurz den Feind ablenken. Chef, er hat einen Punkt.
Naja, okay. Wenn wir wirklich nichts anderes haben, dann lassen wir uns einfach ein paar Federchen abwerfen. Okay, dann treffen wir uns in zwei Jahren wieder und schauen, wie es lief. In zwei Jahren zum Mitnehmen oder zum Hier essen. Aber das ist echt das Ding. Vor allem, ich glaube, die Idee ist einfach, dass wenn da ein Wolf reinbeisst, dass dann die Federn abfliegen, damit es nichts verheddert und das Huhn überhaupt weglaufen kann oder so. Aber weil wirklich eine Waffe ist das nicht so ein Huhn. Ich meine, das ist ein Kissen. Also so Federn sind in Kissen. Das ist wirklich das Unbedrohendste, was es überhaupt gibt. Es ist fast nett. Es ist fast nett, ja. Aber vielleicht kitzelt es auch ein bisschen. Ich weiß gar nicht, ob alle Tiere kitzelig sind. Oder ist der Mensch das einzige Tier des Kitzeligs? Das glaube ich nicht. Nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee. Man kann Kätzchen kitzeln. Wirklich? Man kann Kätzchen kitzeln. Titzel, Kitzel, Tätsel. Titzel, Kitzel, Kasse. Titzel, Kitzel, Kätzchen. Titzel, Kitzel, Katzel, Kasse ist mein YouTube-Tanal. Und da kitzel ich Kätzchen und die merken, das ist doch, doch, doch, man kann auch Delfine kitzeln, aber das soll man nicht. Aber du meinst es nicht so etwas wie Kraulen oder Streicheln, das mögen die ja. Kitzeln ist ja eher so, lass mich in Ruhe. So ein bisschen am Füsschen, die haben ja ganz süße, ganz rosane, weiche Frötchen, wo wenn man da kann sie kitzeln, dann ziehen die die weg. Glaub ich, weiss ich jetzt auch nicht. Weiss ich auch nicht. Aber sehr süss. Top, top unter, also Topsohlen eines Tieres sind Kätzchen bei mir. Ja, ja, definitiv. Aber vielleicht nur bei so Kühen oder so, wenn da so Fliegen kommen, dann wählen die mit dem Schwanz so weg, das könnte wahrscheinlich auch als Kitzel durchgehen. Ja, ja, ja. Wie unfassbar diszipliniert Kühe eigentlich sind, oder? Ruhig, stoisch. Die stehen den ganzen Tag in einem endlosen Meer aus Essen. Dass die nicht den ganzen Tag essen, sondern dass die sagen, aber ich glaube, die sagen so, jetzt ein bisschen, dann zum Mittag noch mal ein Büschel und dann vielleicht zu Kaffee und Kuchen und abends. Ich als, ich glaube, ich wäre eine schlechte Kuh, weil ich könnte mich nicht beherrschen. Wir am Buffet stehen auf dem Buffet den ganzen Tag und essen die konstant. Du weißt nicht, ob sie das mögen. Du weißt nicht, ob das das Einzige ist, was sie haben. Du weißt nicht, ob das so ist, wie für uns in einem Buffet aus Cheese-Bacon-Sandwiches zu stehen, sondern wahrscheinlich ist es für die, als auch wir in so einem Meer aus Porridge. Dann denkt man auch so, ja, könnte ich mich gut beherrschen. Ich habe auf dem Weg hierher, habe ich eine Taube gesehen. Und die Taube stand auf einer Pizza. Die Pizza lag am Boden, weil er weiss, was gestern Abend passiert ist,
an diesem Ort. Wilde Dinge.
Gestern ist hier Pfingstfeier.
Da war einfach eine Pizza und die Taube stand auf der Pizza drauf.
Und da dachte ich mir, die hat
keine Disziplin mehr.
Die geht all fucking in.
Die hat gepickt, als gäbe es kein Morgen.
Taube muss natürlich immer denken,
gleich kommen die anderen, meine
Brüder und Schwestern, aber die hat einfach alles
weggepickt. Die stand
Vielen Dank. So, die hat gepickt, als gäbe's kein Morgen. Taube muss natürlich immer denken, gleich kommen die anderen, meine Brüder und Schwestern, aber die hat einfach alles weggepickt. Die stand einfach in einem Meer aus unendlichem Essen und hat gepickt den Prosciutto. Doch endlich, schon sehr endlich. Ja, für eine Taube ist das unendlich. Am Rande der Pizza ist sehr endlich. Naja, so weit kann eine Taube nicht sein. Ich weiß nicht. Das dachten die Menschen früher auch, dass die Erde unendlich groß ist. Aber es gibt einen unausgesprochenen Deal mit Tauben, dass die zwei im Weg stehen, auf Fahrradwegen stehen, aber weggehen. Ja. Das ist unausgesprochen, aber der Deal ist da. We had a deal. Gehen ein Stück zur Seite. Das ist die Zeitweltfolge. Jedenfalls gerade bin ich am Fahrrad hierher gefahren und sie hat den Deal missachtet und ist nicht gegangen. Und es war wirklich so knapp, da musste ich ausweichen und es war ein Riesenspektakel. Nee, die macht alles kaputt. Ich denke noch. Die musst du verpetzen. Die kriegt auch Anschiss von den anderen Tauben. Ja. So, hey, wir haben einen Deal. Wir dürfen hier in der Stadt sein, dafür gehen wir aus dem Weg. Wir kriegen die geilen Pommes, wir kriegen Pizza, Pommes, Popcorn den ganzen Tag. Wir kriegen alles. Die lassen uns hier sein. Dafür müssen wir nur eine Sache erfüllen, wir müssen im letzten Moment aus dem Weg springen. Denk doch mal nach. Glaubst du, wir wollen
wieder zurück in den scheiß Wald und irgendwelche Würmer
essen oder so? Sei doch einmal schlau!
Sei doch einmal schlau in deinem Leben!
Ich habe ihn nicht gesehen, ich habe ihn nicht gesehen, ich habe ihn nicht gesehen.
Das ist deine Aufgabe, vernam noch mal!
Du musst ihn sehen!
Gucken wir deswegen so schnell von A nach B
Du hast Augen auf beiden Seiten
deines Kopfes, was siehst du denn nicht? Nach vorne. Ja, eben. Ich kann dich gut nach vorne sehen. Verdammt noch mal, reiss dich zusammen, wir hängen ja alle mit drin, die dummen Menschen können uns nicht unterscheiden, für die bist du ich und ich bin du. Ich habe das Gefühl, wir, wirklich, das glaube ich nicht, du hast deutlich mehr Punkte auf deinem Gefiederkleid. Das interessiert dich doch nicht. Auf deinem Gefiederkleid. Kannst du die Menschen auseinanderhalten? Ne, halten? Die sind alle gleiche. Vielleicht ist es auch nur ein Mensch. Naja, sorry, ich verreiss mich zusammen. Okay, der Deal ist, wir flattern einen Meter aus dem Weg, und wenn er dann noch mal kommt, flattern wir einen weiteren Meter. Genau, wenn das dreimal passiert, fliegen wir weg, an einen anderen Ort. Warum riechst du nach Pizza? Hm, Ich habe gefragt, warum. Nein. Nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, Steht wirklich gut. Tizepizza? Pizza-Tizepatien?
Ich glaub dir schon, du musst gar nicht weiterreden.
Ist das dein Traum, mal eine Pizzalandschaft auch zu machen?
Ne, eine Taube zu sein.
Eine Taube zu sein?
Nein, mein grösster Traum wäre es ... Pizza-Titze?
Nee.
Ist das schon gut, oder?
Hast du nicht gesagt, Nomen ist Omen?
War das nicht von dir, oder war das der Papst?
Das war schon von mir.
Ach so.
Urbi et orbi, Nomen ist Omen, das ist schon alles von mir. Heißt ja nicht, dass ich das auch so leben muss. Nur wenn man ein Sprichwort erfindet, heißt ja nicht, verstehe, was du meinst. dass man selber da so leben muss. Ja, ja, ja. Platz zwei Mauser. Platz zwei Mauser ist natürlich die Vollmauser. Ja, also wenn du alles abwirfst, wenn du einfach sagst, weg mit den Federn, alles weg, ich mach Urlaub und einfach nochmal alles neu. Das finde ich auch eine gute Idee. Auch geil, wenn man dann nicht fliegen, also eine gute Ausrede, mal nicht fliegen zu müssen. Ja. Oder sagen die, fuck, jetzt bin ich besonders anfällig oder ist es wirklich, oh, kommst du mit, wir wollen nach Süden. Na, gemausert, sorry, Kollege, geht nicht. Ja, auch alle so, du willst weil du im Norden bleiben willst, oder was? Nee, nee, nee, kann ich nicht weit mitkommen, du, wenn ich jetzt hier so Düsenantrieb hätte oder so, gerne. Aber solange ich auf diese Federn hier angewiesen bin, kein Problem. Übrigens eine Frage, die noch nicht hinreichend beantwortet wurde von das Podcast-Uvo-Publikum, da würde ich mir jetzt eine Antwort wünschen, ist, ist für Vögel fliegen wie für uns joggen? Das haben wir doch schon mal, da haben wir eine Umfrage gemacht. Ja, aber wir haben es noch nicht empirisch beantwortet bekommen, wirklich wissenschaftlich fundiert. Ist für Vögel laufen wie für uns laufen es, beziehungsweise wenn Tauben gehen, ist es für die so wie für uns gehen? Nein, wir hatten die Formel. Was für Tauben stehen ist, ist für uns sitzen. Was für Tauben laufen ist, ist für uns stehen. Was für Tauben fliegen ist, ist für uns gehen. Und was für Tauben schwimmen ist, ist für uns rennen. Das ist für die besonders ansteigend. Und auf Enden, glaube ... Enten sind ja komplett raus. Deren Schwimmen ist für uns Sitzen. Sitzen Enten nicht immer? Im Wasser. Ja, die können ja im Wasser auch ... Ich glaube, deren Schwimmen ist für uns wie normales Sitzen. Deren Fliegen, kann ich mir vorstellen, ist unser leichtes Joggen. Ja, Tiere lehnen gar nicht, ne? Gibt es Tiere, die sich irgendwo anlehnen? Ja, ja, doch. Die machen wirklich so, pfuh, Straussen, Vogelstraussen, die lehnen sich gegen so einen Baum, der in der Sabanne steht. Dann auch mit so verschränkten Flügeln vor dem Körper und dann so, oh. So, ich war eigentlich, wir haben uns hier verabredet für den Mittag. Einen Fuß stellen die so hoch und lehnen den auch noch an. Aber gibt's selten, dass ein Bär sich so mit einem Arm dann so ... So, ich war eigentlich, wir haben uns hier verabredet für Mittag. Einen Fuß stellen die so hoch und lehnen den auch noch an.
Aber gibt's selten, dass ein Bär sich so mit einem Arm oder so,
ein Bär vielleicht am ehesten noch, oder, weil die sich auch so kratzen am Baum?
Ja, am Bauch.
Aber mausolehnende Tiere?
Tiere lehnen nicht, wir lehnen hingegen.
Tiere sitzen auch immer auf dem Boden, die setzen sich auch nicht ...
Nee, gibt's nicht, gibt's nicht. Google sagt nein. Leaning animals. Doch, da gibt's ein kleines Pferd, das lehnt gegen seine Mutter. Das lehnt einfach so dagegen. Tiere sind nicht kitzlig, Tiere lehnen sich ... Was können eigentlich Tiere? Die sind fucking weird. Wir werden Tiere auch nie ganz verstehen. Glaubst du, wenn man mit Tieren sprechen könnte, würden wir näher in Richtung Beantwortung der Frage, was ist der Sinn des Lebens kommen, wenn man mit Tieren sprechen könnte? Ich glaube schon. Weil ich glaube, Tiere haben teilweise eher verinnerlicht, worum es im Leben geht, als wir. Wir sind so überkomplex. Ja genau, die Taube denkt Pizza, Pizza, Pizza, Pizza, Pizza, Pizza, Pizza, Pizza, Pizza, Pizza, ja, Pizza, Pizza, Pizza. Oh, verteidigen, verteidigen, verteidigen, aus dem Weg, aus dem Weg, Auto, Auto, Scheinwerfer, zurück, Pizza. Ich stehe auf Pizza. Das ist halt, und im Endeffekt ist das doch, worum es geht. Ja. Fortpflanzen, Pizza, schlafi, schlafi, schlafi, schlafi. Ja. Niemals anlehnen. Niemals anlegen, überleben.
Überleben.
Ja.
Anlehnen, nein, nein.
Gut, aber da ist jetzt World of Warcraft kein Teil der Sache.
Deswegen kann ich jetzt gar nicht connecten zu sowas.
Du kannst gar nicht connecten?
Null.
Okay, ja.
Gut, aber vermutlich, haben Tiere Spaß?
Können Tiere auch Spaß haben?
Also spielen die auch teilweise?
Ja, gute Frage.
Also Hunde hat man schon manchmal das Gefühl, dass diese, weil das ist ja so ein Spiel für die. So eine Bombe finden ist ja für einen Hund wie ein Spiel. Der lernt es ja wie ein Spiel. Der freut sich ja auch, dass er die Bombe gefunden hat. Und der Mensch freut sich auch, aber aus anderen Gründen. Aber der Hund hat jetzt einfach ein Spiel gespielt. Erst machst du das mit so einem Spielzeug, dann gibst du denen so Leckerlis oder was. Der Hund checkt nicht, dass er gerade irgendwie was super Gefährliches macht oder so, sondern der macht ein Spiel. Für den ist es einfach so, okay, ich habe gewonnen, ich habe die Bombe gefunden oder die Drogen gefunden oder was auch. Ja, die Leiche, die Leichengeruch. Was immer ein bisschen merkwürdig ist, der Hund freut sich dann, wenn er einen Leichengeruch wahrnimmt, werdet seinen Schwanz und bellt laut und er freut sich. Aber alle Menschen in der Runde werden super ernst und super uncool und unschämlich. Aber eigentlich, der Trainer muss sich ja auch freuen, damit der Hund das richtige Feedback kriegt. Das heißt, ja toll, hast du die Leiche gefunden, ja super hast du das gemacht. Weil der Hund weiß ja glaube ich gar nicht, was er da sucht. Der assoziiert ja nur diesen bestimmten Geruch mit, ich krieg was, ich mach was Gutes, aber was er da jetzt sucht, checkt er da auch nicht genau, oder? Das heißt, er weiß gar nicht, dass er ein Drogenspürhund ist. Neulich in der Bahn lief ein Hund herum, ein grosser Hund mit so einer Weste, irgendwie so ein Sicherheits-Comforting-Hund von der Bahn. Hast du den mal gesehen? Nee, von der Bahn? Ja, der hat so ein Bahn-Branding, so ein Brennzeichen auf dem Feld. DB! Mir ist eine riesengroße Hündin. Schon irgendwie, hallo, mein Name ist Susi und ich bin ein Komforthund. Mit einem Hundemensch. Da war ein Hundemensch dabei. Aber ich weiß nicht, ob man die nicht dann, weil da ging es mir auch nicht gut, war es sehr voll. Das habe ich ja noch nie erlebt. Es war zu voll im Abteil, da wollte ich diesen Comforting-Hund haben, der sollte bei mir bleiben.
Und den kann man dann ordern? Das weiß ich nicht.
Es lief zu schnell vorbei.
Aber ich glaube,
du bist ja sicher, dass du das nicht missverstanden hast.
Ja, es war kein Blindenhund
und es war auch jetzt nicht,
es war so wie so ein, ich weiß nicht,
ein Komforthund. Und wenn es einem schlecht geht, dann kann man
den Hund holen und dann streicheln. Ich habe nicht genau... Das ist ja verrückt. Ich fahre jede Woche mit der Bahn, das habe ich noch nie erlebt. Und Wahnsinn. Braucht er ein Ticket? Oder wie ist das? Ne, ne, sie ist Mitarbeiterin. Oder der hat eine Bahncard 100. Susi ist Mitarbeiterin, Susi hat eine Bahncard 100 und fährt mit. Geil. Kriegt wahrscheinlich sogar Geld der Bahn, in Leckerlis aufgezahlt. Sie wollte in Leckerlis aufgezahlen. Und Urlaubstage, fünf Urlaubstage im Jahr. Ich weiß nicht genau, was sie war. Vielleicht für Menschen mit, ähm. Ja, das kann schon sein, wenn dann irgendwie so Epileptiker oder irgendwie sowas dabei sind, dass dann so ein Hund dabei ist, der dann helfen kann. Aber, ich weiß ja auch nicht genau. Das war auch so ein großer, flauschiger Hund, also so ein Lieber, so ein Bernardiner-artiger, total niedlich, irre niedlich, alle haben dem hinterher geguckt und fand es schön. Riesig, auch riesiger Hund lief da rum, hat den ganzen Weg versperrt, alle Notausgänge. So lange er telefoniert, kann er von mir aus mitfahren. Aber dieses Mal kam zum ersten Mal eine Durchsage auch, der Zug ist zu voll, wir müssen manchmal bitten, auszusteigen. Und das ist wirklich... Ja, wie wär's mit dem Hund, mit dem riesigen Hund. Ja, riesigen Hund. Die Leute stellen Notausgänge zu mit ihren Koffern. Ja, gut, war zu voll. Aber da kann ja niemand was für. Das ist so schlimm, diese Aussage. Wir wollen alle ans Ziel, wir wollen alle nicht gerade hier sein, wir wollen alle lieber zu Hause sein. Wir sind halt nur mal in der Bahn. Ist ja nicht so, dass ich irgendwie, und dann wurde diese Ansagerin immer gefieser und gemeiner und patziger und man denkt, ja, aber niemand ist ja jetzt hier aus Spaß, niemand fällt ja gerne von A nach B, wir wollen alle an unser Ziel, niemand hat da mehr Recht zu oder weniger Recht zu. Das ist so eine doofe Ansage. Das ist furchtbar, vor allem, also wir müssen auch nochmal über das Neun-Euro-Ticket reden, weil ich finde, noch nie gab es einen
unkreativeren Namen für ein Ticket.
Ich meine, wir haben das Hallo-Wochenende-Ticket,
das Geh-mir-aus-dem-Weg-Ticket, das
Ich-will-einfach-nur-nach-Bayern-Ticket.
Alle diese Tickets haben coole Namen.
Nur vor allem, kein
Freizeitpark der Welt kann jetzt
sagen, für Neun-Euro-Tagesticket, Neun-Euro-Ticket.
Ich finde, es ist einfach eine Anmassung,
ich finde es einfach dreist von der Bahn, dass du diese Kosten einfach so direkt als Name deines Tickets machst, so. Lass dir da doch irgendwas einfallen. Ich finde diese neun Euro, auf die man sich da geeinigt hat, auch ganz, ganz komisch. Ja. Weil es ist so, eigentlich wollten sie einen Zehner, aber wollten es dann noch ein bisschen attraktiver machen. Vielleicht gab es schon ein Zehn-Euro-Ticket, vielleicht hat es schon mal irgendeine Eisdiele in Bad Reuler. Hat irgendwie gesagt, für das 10-Euro-Ticket, 10 Euro im Jahr, kriegst du so viel Eis, wie du essen kannst. 10-Euro-Abo. Ja, 10-Euro-Abo. Und dann hat die Barling gesagt, fuck. Und das ist nämlich genau das Problem mit den Fernsehsendern. Wenn es mal ein ProSieben gibt, kann ich nicht sagen, jetzt mache ich Satz-Sieben, sondern das geht halt nicht. Die Zahl ist besetzt. Die Zahl ist dann besetzt. So. Und du musst dann einfach, wenn du jetzt einen neuen Fernsehender gründen musst, musst du dann halt Tizze 13 machen, weil halt alles bis zwölf schon voll ist. Und du kannst dann nur noch die 13 nehmen. Weil jeder kennt Kabel 12, ne? Ich weiß gar nicht, wo wir aktuell sind. Tele fünf, Satz sechs, sieben, acht, Tele fünf Mach du mal Tizze 13 einfach so für deine Grusel- und Geistershow, wo dann nur so Horrorprogramm läuft, machst du dann Tizze 13? Tizze 13. Tizze 13, gleich geht's weiter mit den neuesten Sendungen rund um Geisterspuk und Mumien. Aber findest du das nicht gemein, weil ich meine, das 9-Euro-Ticket soll ja einen Anreiz bieten, dass man fahren darf, dass viele Leute fahren können. Es ist einfacher, billiger, mit der Bahn zu fahren. Dafür ist das Neun-Euro-Ticket gut. Warum dann überhaupt, weil es ist ja, wahrscheinlich kriegen sie damit nicht wahnsinnig viel, also es ist ja nicht ein Mittel, um Geld zu verdienen, sondern es ist jetzt mal so ein Anreiz, ein Incentive, Bahn zu fahren, um jetzt nicht Auto zu fahren. Warum nicht umsonst machen? Ja, gute Frage. Das ist nicht fast eine Beleidigung, ist nicht fast ... Ich glaube, innerhalb dieses Raumes werden wir diese Frage nicht klären. Da müssen wir schon raus in die Welt. Wir machen jetzt die Pester auf. Wir können es probieren. Vielleicht kommt eine Antwort rein. Mal schauen, vielleicht werfen Leute eine Antwort rein. Ich weiß es nicht. Keine Ahnung, es stimmt total. Aber ich bin gespannt. Wir sind jetzt bald unterwegs nach Wien. Meine Idee war, der Zug ist wirklich sehr lang von Köln nach Wien. Ich glaube, da fährt man so neun Stunden oder sowas. Kann man halt mal machen. Oder was natürlich die viel coolere Alternative wäre, wäre Nachtzüge. Mal in so einem Schlafwagen nach Wien zu fahren, zum Live-Auftritt, das finde ich total cool. Ja, so richtig Mord im Polen-Express. Ja, ich komme ausgeschlafen und mit einem gelösten Mordfall und Schleudertrauma nach Wien an, habe viel zu erzählen. Also, das fände ich ganz geil. Also, warum Nachtzüge generell nicht in grösserer Beliebtheit sich erfreuen. Also, wahrscheinlich liegt es da an den Anbietern, ich glaube, die Nachfrage wäre riesig. Nachtzüge? Irre. Also von gerade Europa, wo man einigermaßen nah beieinander ist. Wenn die Leute es schon nicht auf die Reihe kriegen, in einem Ruheabteil leise zu sein, wie soll das funktionieren, wenn du dann in so einem Nachtzug bist und da rumschreitst? Da ist dein eigenes Abteil, da machst du dann einfach Fenster zu. Ja gut, dann ist das natürlich cool. Aber die Vorstellung, eigen zu schlafen und während man fährt die ganze Zeit, ist doch toll. Kann man da so rausschauen aus dem Fenster? Ich will zieh dann einem vorbei. Am besten stellst du dir vor, ganz ganz hinten zu schlafen, im allerletzten Zug. Und dann nach hinten raus zu gucken. Und dann hast du vielleicht so eine kleine Terrasse. Und dann hast du vielleicht so eine kleine Terrasse, stellst du so einen Stühl raus. Und dann setzt du dich da hinten und guckst hinten raus, wie die Gleise hinter dir langsam verschwinden. Wie die Welt die Gleise auffrisst. Wie die Welt die Gleise am Horizont verschwinden. Die Gläser am Horizont verbinden. Du bist Autor nochmal? Neun Erfolgsrebat. Ich bin neun Euro Autor. Alle Bücher für neun Euro. Alle kosten neun Euro. Dasze-Garantie. Alle Bücher neun Euro. Ich habe letztens etwas Unfassbares rausgefunden, wo wir bei Büchern sind. Und zwar, die wunderbare Welt des Herr der Ringe wird immer weirder. Ja? Es wird immer Stranger. Es ist unglaublich, weil ich habe wirklich, weil ich beschäftige mich schon, glaube ich, recht lange mit Herr der Ringe. Als Kind habe ich Filme gesehen, Bücher gelesen, Karten gespielt, Brettspiel gespielt. Hast du alle Bücher gelesen? Ja, ich habe alle Bücher gelesen. Ich habe erst den ersten Film gesehen, dann habe ich alle Bücher gelesen und eigentlich den zweiten Film gelesen. Weil durch den ersten Film kam ich drauf. Weil wir haben neulich ja so einen Gen-Z-Kid kennengelernt, beruflich, wir beiden, der auch alle Bücher gelesen hat von Herr der Ringe. Gen-Z sind krass, die sind krasser als wir in ihr in sich. Wir müssen nochmal, genauso wie wir
das Neun-Euro-Tagere reden mussten, ganz, ganz ausführlich über Gen Z
sprechen. Ja, die sind krass.
Und deswegen dachte ich eigentlich, ich kenne mich relativ gut mit
Herr der Ringe aus. Aber, stellt sich
raus, ich habe gar keine Ahnung, weil
alles, was ich über Herr der Ringe jemals dachte, ist falsch.
Zum Beispiel, Frodo
Beutlin heißt nicht Frodo Beutlin.
So heißt er nicht.
Frodo Baggins. Der heißt nicht Frodo Baggins.
Frodo Lean Baggins.
Der heißt so nicht. Denn
Vielen Dank. Frodo Beutlin heißt nicht Frodo Beutlin. So heißt er nicht. Frodo Baggins. Der heißt nicht Frodo Baggins. Frodo Lean Baggins. Der heißt so nicht. Denn Tolkien war ja besonders wichtig, dass er sozusagen den Eindruck erweckt, dass das alte mythologische Erzählungen sind, die da stattfinden. Und deswegen geht Tolkien davon aus, dass nicht er sozusagen den Herr der Ringe geschrieben hat, sondern nur übersetzt hat.
Das heißt, diese ganzen Geschichten, diese ganzen Legenden, diese ganzen Figuren existieren alle in ihren eigenen Sprachen und Tolkien übersetzt die ins Englische.
Weil natürlich haben die nicht Englisch gesprochen, aber das Buch selber ist ja in Englisch. Das heißt, Tolkien hat die alle übersetzt. Und Tolkien hat auch die Namen der Figuren übersetzt. Das heißt, die heißen in ihrer Hobbit-Sprache oder Gondor-Sprache oder was auch immer, heißen die alle anders. Das heißt, Tolkien hat für jede Figur sich mehrere Namen überlegt und die dann übersetzt. Und auch der Begriff Hobbit zum Beispiel, ganz fantastisch, gibt es eigentlich gar nicht, sondern es ist eine Übersetzung und die Übersetzung ergibt sogar Sinn. Weil ursprünglich ist das Ganze nämlich geschrieben in der Sprache Westron. Westron ist einfach die Originalsprache und Tolkien hat das Ganze übersetzt ins Englische. Und zum Beispiel kommt Hobbits, Hobbits heißen ursprünglich Kuduk. Und die hat Tolkien übersetzt, und zwar von ursprünglich Hole-Dweller. Hobbits ist ursprünglich aus dem Alten Englisch Hole-Büttler, was aus Hol, Hole und Büttler, Bilder kommt. Das heißt, Hobbit heißt einfach Holebilder übersetzt. Das heißt, es ist eine Verenglischung von diesem Begriff. Aber jetzt hat man natürlich einen Fehler gemacht, einen großen Fehler, quasi als deutscher Übersetzer von Tolkiens Werk, nicht wieder zurückzugehen und sich mal diesen ganzen Quatsch durchzulesen, sondern einfach jetzt quasi einfach Frodo, man hat zumindest Beutlin aus Baggins gemacht. Man hat nicht das Original übersetzt, man hat das Englische übersetzt, aber nicht das Original. Aber es wäre viel cooler, wenn die Hobbits im Deutschen Lochbuddler, was ja wirklich wahnsinnig nah an der Originalsprache gewesen wäre. Ja, genau. Das heißt, das ist alles nur übersetzt. Das heißt, auch die Eigennamen wurden übersetzt. Also sowas wie Frodo Bergens, heißt gar nicht so. Weißt du, wie Frodo Original heißt? Nein. Also Kuduks, Hobbits sind Kuduks, dann ist Frodo wahrscheinlich Dennis Meierling. Frodo heißt Maura Labinki. Moment, Maura La als Vorname oder Labinki? Maura ist der Vorname. Labinki, wie La Fee. Maura ist der Vorname. Maura. Labinki ist der Nachnamen. So, und jetzt ein Fantastisch ... Er hat gewonnen, er hat gewonnen.
Und ein fantastisches Detail fand ich, weil natürlich gibt es Hardcore-Herr-der-Ringe-Fans, die das alles wissen und die teilweise die Figuren auch mit ihren echten Namen bezeichnen, um sich von den ganzen Mainstream-Fans abzuheben. Und die meinten auch, naja, ich fand es, also zum Beispiel, das ist ja ein Filmfehler, weil ganz am Ende von Teil drei schreibt ja Frodo den Hobbit zu Ende und unterschreibt mit Frodo. Aber die sagen, das ist ja eigentlich falsch, Frodo müsste ja eigentlich mit Maura Labinki unterschreiben. Und jetzt stell dir mal diesen Film vor, drei Teile lang schaust du die an und ganz am Ende unterschreibt die Hauptfigur mit Maura Labinki und der ganze Kinosaal so What? The fuck? Was? Maura Labinki? Allein die Vorstellung, dass man sowas tatsächlich in den Film tun würde, nur um die Hardcore-Technische gesehen ist eigentlich nicht korrekt, aber stell dir Peter Jackson vor,
der sagt, na, eigentlich muss der Maura am Ende stehen.
Nein, muss er ja, nee, nee,
nee, nee, schreib mal Maura
Labinky und auch in Leitze Wut so.
Was? Was? Nee, Maura Labinky?
Du hast dein Originalname, Maura Labinky.
Und vor allem nach dieser riesigen
epochalen Sage, emotionaler Abschluss und das Publikum so was? Das ist die Letztemotion dieser gesamten Trilogie. Tränen noch nicht getrocknet und dann schreibt der Maurer Labinki und du hast so ein schniefendes Hä? Ich habe drei Filme lang einer Lüge zugeschaut. Wahnsinn. Frodo war sein Spitzname. Frodo war der englische Name. Niemand würde ihn jemals Frodo nennen, weil es gibt ja keine Engländer in der Herr der Ringe. Also das ist ja Quatsch. Aber das habe ich auch nicht ganz verstanden, weil es gibt zwei Sprachen in den Filmen. Es gibt Elbisch und es gibt Deutsch, also Englisch. Ja. Je nachdem. So. Die heisst ja, dass alle, also mein, ist ja nicht in Glorious Basterds-mäßig versucht, noch Antonio Margarete, diese Szenen gibt es ja nicht. Es gibt ja keine Übersetzungsszenen, ausser halt Elbisch, Englisch. Heisst ja, und sowas wie Melon oder so, wo dann kurz, Moment mal, das ist die zwergische
Sprache. Sprich Freund und Trich
und alle Zwerge, die wir sehen, sprechen
diese Sprache aber nicht so. Das sind dann, kurz kommen
solche Momente durch und sich, da darf man
nicht zu lange drüber nachdenken,
weil man sagt, ja die Zwerge können ja aber auch
andere, die können das auch, die Normalsprache
sprechen. Ja genau, aber die Orks, mit denen unterhalten
sich alle ganz normal. Und wir sind
sogar bei Szenen, wo nur Orks untereinander sprechen.
Ja.
Und die sprechen auch ihre Sprache.
Englisch.
Und Saruman spricht manchmal mit so einem Urukai auch Englisch.
Ja.
Aber gut, aber die haben die ja gezüchtet.
Und auch Sauron spricht auch Englisch.
Der hat ja auch so, gib mir den Ring, gib mir den Ring bitte!
Ich weiß nicht genau, wie er auf den Film klingt, aber bitte, bitte, gib mir den Ring jetzt, bitte, bitte, bitte Ring, rein da bitte.
Oh, ich liebe Ringe. Ring, ding, ding, ding, ding, rein da.
Dann macht er morgens so auf, dann geht das Auge so auf, wisst ihr, worauf ich heute Bock habe? und so, ja, wahrscheinlich Ring.
Ja, ein Ring! Ring, Ring, Ring, Ring, Ring!
Er schreit den ganzen Tag rum.
Aber es ist absoluter Wahnsinn, absoluter Wahnsinn.
Auch die Vorschriften, Maura Labinki. Er hat wirklich gewonnen mit seinem neuen Namen. Und jede Figur in Herr der Ringe hat Tolkien sich noch mal einen Originalnamen ausgedacht, von dem das nur gesetzt. Das steht ja nirgendwo. Das kriegst du ja nicht mit, wenn du dieses Buch liest. Das ist ja, vor allem, wo ich mir auch denke, aber da bin ich mir nicht hundertprozentig sicher, dass es nicht so eine Art Ur-Tolkien gibt, weil die Frage ist ja, wer schreibt den Herr der Ringe ursprünglich? Das glaube ich ist dann schon Tolkien, der sozusagen diese alten Mythen-Legenden nimmt, übersetzt und dann in eine Geschichte bringt. Aber er hätte ja auch noch so eine Figur, das ist so irgendwie so ein Katull oder so ein Homer sich ausdenken können, der ursprünglich er ist und dessen Texte er nur übersetzt. Das heißt, er selber hat Hederinge gar nicht geschrieben in seiner Welt, sondern nur übersetzt. Aber das gibt es nicht, weil der Hobbit Er will schon aus Eitelkeit, er will schon die Credits für seinen Berge. Ja klar, aber ich glaube, der Hobbit wurde ja von Maura geschrieben, in der Geschichte, glaube ich. Ach so, ja, genau, klar, ja. Hat ja, also Maura die Geschichte von Bongi oder wie auch immer Bilbo heißt, aber also der Film suggeriert das, dass Maura das geschrieben hat. Ja, aber ich bin mir nicht hundertprozentig sicher, ob es tatsächlich in der Lore so ist. Oder ob, ich glaube, der hat nur das Ende geschrieben und Bilbo hat eigentlich oder Bengi oder wie auch immer Bilbo heißt, hat das ursprünglich geschrieben. Aber wie heissen denn alle anderen? Schaut euch das mal an. Das ist ein schöner Nachmittag. Schaut euch mal, Original Names gibt es da und das ist wirklich obskur, weil manche auch nicht übersetzt wurden. Also viele Begriffe, also gerade so diese elbischen Sachen wurden nicht übersetzt.. Also das ist ganz absurd. Aber allein der Aufwand zu sagen für diese hunderten Figuren, die ich mir ausgedacht habe, jeder hat zwei Namen. Jeder hat einfach zwei Namen. Und den einen Namen, den kriegt nie jemand zu Gesicht. Der steht nirgendwo. Aber auch gut, dass bei Bilbo steht Death Unknown, Last Sighting, 29. September. Das heißt, Tolkien hat sich die Mühe gegeben, sämtliche Sprachen erfunden, eine riesen neue Welt erfunden, Religionen, Kulturen, alles erfunden, hat sich selber nur als Gesammler dieser Geschichten und Verfasser der Geschichte bezeichnet, aber die letzte Sichtung von Bilbo ist am 29. September. September 2008. So, wo man auch denkt, da hättest du dir auch noch mal die Mühe mehr geben können und irgendwie eine neue Zeitrechnung erfinden können. Okay, aber das ist wirklich total interessant, weil er ist für mich der Inbegriff von überbordendem Fleiss. Ja. Tolkien. Fünf Sprachen entwickelt, alles. Genau, also viel zu Sachen, die man nicht braucht, aber natürlich ist auch wieder die Frage, braucht man das nicht doch? Also war nicht für den Erfolg von Herr der Ringe und jetzt auch diese Tiefe in diesem Fantum nicht auch entscheidend, dass es so viele neue Sprachen erfunden wurden und halt so viel Wissen, so viel Lore. Das Interessante ist ja, dass diese eigentliche Geschichte mit den Ring in den Bergwerfen und den Trollen, das war ja wahrscheinlich für Tolkien nur so nebensächlich so, der hat ja nur diese riesige Welt gebaut mit den Sprachen, das ist eigentlich, im Grunde ist das wie so, wenn du Französisch lernst, so dieses, ah, where is the tourist information bureau, so ist eigentlich die Herr-der-Ring-Geschichte, der wollte halt nur seine Sprache mal benutzen und seine Welt. Dom de Esther, Mount Doom. Genau, und dann so, oh, diese Geschichte ist brillant, die müssen wir verfilmen. Und Tolkien so, was, den Kram? Das sind nur so Beispielsätze, nur die so, so Gedichte und so, das sind alles nur so Beispielsachen, wie das alles funktionieren könnte. Das glaube ich, hat ihn überhaupt nicht so interessiert. Und das wird verfilmt einfach. Ja, ja, genau. Und einfach elf Oscars. Für die Sprache? Für die Gedichte?
Nee, nee, für die Szene, wo
Negolas den Troll in den Kopf schießt.
Das war so cool, wie die nämlich da mit dem Stich und dann Dimitri hemmt.
Ach so, du meinst ja, wo er dann so in der elbischen Grammatik austritt, weil die ändert sich, je nach Gefühlslage, ändert sich die elbische Grammatik.
Nee, es gab Make-up-Oscar.
Ach so.
Escon.
Okay.
Naja. Wie heißt Oscar in deiner Sprache? Bordep. Bordep, Labinky. Vor allem, ich meine, das wirst du ja kennen, das Nervigste, was es gibt am Autor sein, ist sich Namen ausdenken, weil das ist random, aber irgendwie auch super wichtig. Und allein sich die Mühe zu machen, für jeden zwei ... Ich zwei ... Kannst du nicht auch bei How to Sell Drugs noch so eine tiefen Ebene mit reinbringen? Die Figuren haben eigentlich, das sind eigentlich alles keltische Geistwesen, die nur reinkarniert sind in diese Jugendlichen, aber die haben alle noch mal neue Namen. So eine völlig unnötige Fantasy-Lore, die irgendwo in obskuren Foren diskutiert wird, die in der Serie aber schlicht nicht vorkommt. Hau das einfach nach oben drauf. Ja, ich finde das auch sehr gut. Einfach noch so Addendum, einfach dann noch so das Silmarillion, das How to Sell Drugs Rillion, wo einfach nochmal alles in Kontext gesetzt wird. Drug Rillion. Dass das ursprünglich riesige Yin-Yang-Antagonismen sind zwischen Polizei und Verbrechen, Jugend und Alter. Die seit Jahren Riesenkampf haben und jetzt in dieser neuen Zeitwende, in dritten Zeitrechnung. Und es war eigentlich damals die Welten-Schlange im tibetanischen Glauben reinkarniert, jetzt als Moritz. Das finde ich auch nicht gut. Auch so wie Rowling und so, die im Nachhinein noch immer so dann rummischt und Sachen korrigiert und so. Ja, aber es ist unnötiger Fleiss und du machst immer, ja, ich weiß nicht, also klar, wie ich gerade auch meinte, vielleicht hilft es ja dem Fantum, auf der anderen Seite ist es einfach nur unnötiger Scheiss. Du schreib doch einfach deinen Drecksbücher und die Geschichte und dann wirft er den Ring da rein und gut ist. Danach noch so ein Addendum, da hat dann niemand mehr Lust drauf und der war so fleissig anscheinend. Wor er war davongelaufen? Weißt man, wo Folkend davongelaufen ist? Ich glaube, das ist noch nicht klar. Aber ich glaube, Pferde. Pferde sind immer ... Weil die hinter dem Meer gelaufen sind. Gefährlich. Und irgendwelche so schwarz vermantelten Leute oder so was. Nach wie vor unglaublich gruselig. Die Filme sind alle fantastisch gealtert. Außer Teil drei mit diesem weirden Special-Effects-Shit. Mit den Geistern? Der Geister, ja. Ja ... Geister gefiel mir nicht visuell. Ja, das ist auch so ein Ding, so ... Ja, okay, du hast hier diese unbesiegbare Geisterarmee, aber nur für eine Schlacht. Ja, dann lass uns Mordor direkt angreifen und den Ring wegwerfen. Nee, lass uns ... Nee, lass uns diese eine Schlacht dann doch für Gonder nehmen. Nee, das macht Sinn, weil die mussten nämlich ... Dem König von Gondor den Heid leisten. Genau, also deswegen macht es schon Sinn, dass die dann Gondor verteidigen. Ja. Aber ja, ich weiß nicht. Aber genau, ja. Jetzt kann man das nicht anders auslegen. Wir helfen Gondor ja mehr, wenn wir jetzt nach Mordor reiten. Ja, ich hätte auch eine Szene gefunden, wo Aragons so sagt so, Herr Shit, wahrscheinlich hätte mir die Schlacht auch ohne die Geister gewonnen, oder? Fuck. Ich meine, wir hatten den ganzen Rohan da und so und die Ortefanten waren zur Hälfte tot. Fuck die Ortefanten! Fuck! Na gut, das ist nur eine Special Edition. Die Ortefanten. Das kam in der Kinofassung gar nicht vor. Ja, die Masopilame sind Orte hätten wir auch so im Kopf. Der Fruchttiger ist auch nur Special Edition, glaube ich. Wo einfach diese Schlacht ausartet, Battle of the Nineteen Armies. Leute, Leute, Leute, was macht denn das Michelin-Männchen jetzt hier? Das hätte ich ja bei Avengers Endgame auch gar nicht vor, wenn er einfach das Masopilami mitkämpft. Und Toucan Sam einfach so. What, alle Universen, wir brauchen jeden, den wir kriegen, wir brauchen jeden. Dr. Strange hat gesagt, wir brauchen jeden, den wir kriegen. Und Lars Kritze ist auch gekostet. Warum nicht den Bärenmarke? Sollen wir dann Lars Kritze sagen, nein, du darfst dich mitkämpfen? Nein, ich meine, Lars Kritze sagt, der Bärenmarke, der ist da, der kann fast nichts. Ja, genau. Außerdem wird es jetzt auch ein markenrechtliches Problem. Also ich fühle mich unterrepräsentiert. Wir haben Schwierigkeiten. Ach, das finde ich nicht so schlecht. Ja, mega. Ja, aber das hat mir nicht so gefallen. Also diese Armee da hinten, diese, das fand ich dann... Das ist dein Kritikpunkt an elf Oscars. Ja, hinten. Stefan, also Academy sagt elf Oscars, Stefan Thieze sagt, ja, dieser eine Effekt. Zehn Sternchen. Aber ich fand es lustig, als ich dann mal die Star-Wars-Dokumentation guckte, das Making-of von Episode 1 und 2 und 3, da gibt es ja ganz tolle Videos bei YouTube. Da gab es so eine Zeit, da gab es eine enorme Diskrepanz zwischen, was Computer können und wie sie aussehen. Ja. Gibt es nicht mehr. Das stimmt. Weil inzwischen sind die, wenn gut gemacht, die grafischen Effekte alle mindblowing, fotorealistisch und die Computer sehen auch aus. Ja, super Flat Screen, Leuchten, Lüftung. Genau, aber dann gab es so 98, 99, als so die Prequels gemacht wurden, gab es halt diese Windows 98 Rechner, die wir alle kennen. Grauen Quadrate. Diese grauen, dicken Würfel mit einer 12 Pixeln Auflösung und so. Wenn man sich dann aber zum Beispiel das Podracing anguckt, einfach fotorealistisches Rennen von Raumschiffen. Immer noch. Bis heute ein fantastischer Teil. Sieht unglaublich echt aus. Wurde gemacht von so zwölf Leuten an diesen Windows-98-Rechner. Das kann ich mir einfach nicht erklären. Das ist Wahnsinn. Und wenn du dir anguckst bei diesem Making-of, du hast einfach Leute vor Windows-98 sitzen mit Windows-98-artigen Grafiken auch. Dann ziehen die da so Striche und malen dann so mit Paint diesen Potracer von Sebulba und es sieht alles extrem scheiße aus.
Nämlich so wie unsere Games
auf dem Windows-98-Rechner.
So wie Tomb Raider. Und dann sagen die ja, und dann haben die
daran gesessen und dann sieht man so
diese hässliche Zeichnung von denen,
wirklich mit Paint gezeichnet
und dann gibt es diesen typischen
Behind-the-Scenes-Making-of-Strich.
Ja, diese Wischer dann. Diese Wischer und dann ist es fotorealistisch rechts. Und ich so, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne und es sieht scheiße aus und dann, ja, jetzt muss es rendern eine Woche und dann ist es super. Niemand weiß genau, was da passiert. Man will auch nicht so scharf nachfragen, sonst geht's kaputt. Wenn du zu häufig einen Renner fragst, dann löst sich das Problem auf. Ja, genau. Und dann ist es so, puff, puff das. Ja, das fand ich, das war weird. Inzwischen gibt es das nicht mehr, aber früher gab es so eine große Diskrepanz zwischen, was die Technik leisten kann und was der Mensch aber daraus gemacht hat. Inzwischen wurden wir irgendwie faul. Also wir können viel, viel weniger, finde ich,, wenn man sich heute ins Kino geht und Marvel-Filme anguckt,
sind die hässlicher als die Bildschirme und die Rechner
und die Renderfarmen, die suggerieren, was wir eigentlich können müssen.
Die Technik hat uns überholt.
Wir waren mal cleverer als die Technik,
jetzt ist die Technik besser als wir,
und wir wissen nicht, was damit machen sollen.
Wir sind noch so ein Anhängsel, das auch abgestossen werden kann irgendwann. Genau. Wir merken es besonders dadurch, dass unsere Mikrofone so stark rauschen die ganze Zeit. Das hört ihr nicht, aber wir hören die ganze Zeit so ein Seit Wochen kriegen wir das nicht unter Kontrolle. Es ist einfach da irgendwie so, wahrscheinlich ist das irgendwie so ein Schmetterlingsei. Am Ende ist dann doch ein Schmetterlingsei im Kabel drin oder so. Das denke ich mir eh immer. Warum hat die Tierwelt die Technikwelt noch nicht mehr vereinnahmt oder so? Weil es gibt in der Natur so krasse Sachen. Es gibt ja so Parasiten, die pflanzen sich in Gehirne ein und die sorgen dafür, dass das Wirttier dann genau dahin läuft. Also brutale
Sachen, wo ich mir denke, warum
machen die das nicht in der Natur? Warum nisten
sich Vögel nicht irgendwie in so Strom-
Mastenkästen ein? Und irgendwann mal so ein Rockkonzert.
Ja, genau. Achtung, Achtung!
Hier sprechen die Spatzen.
Ja. Wir haben eure Sound-PA
infiltriert. Ja.
Wir wollen folgendes. Mais.
Mais. Mehr Mais. Mehr Knödel. Mais, Mais, Mais, Mais, Mais, Mais. Ja, dass sich so Parasiten in so eine Radiostation einarbeiten und da einpflanzen und da das Radioprogramm kapern. Mega creepy sagen. Wir wollen Blut. Gebt uns Blut, Menschen Blut. Es muss doch rein evolutionär, weil es gibt ja mittlerweile
es gibt ja auf der ganzen Welt
Strom, Stromleitungen, Strom,
überall magnetische Felder. Das muss
doch auf die Evolution langsam mal
Einfluss haben, dass Tiere lernen,
Strom zu nutzen
oder so magnetische Felder, so kompassmässig
dann sich zu orientieren, dass
die das aufgreifen.
Die sind nur langsam, Tiere sind nur langsam, die sind schlau, aber langsam. Irgendwann wird es ja so eine Maus geben, die einfach mit Strom läuft, die einfach nicht mehr essen muss, sondern halt einfach dann in so ein Kabel reinbeisst, sich auflädt und das ist ja nicht, also das geht doch bestimmt. Ich meine, die Evolution ja knackt doch irgendwann diesen Stromcode.
Die haben ja quasi alles mögliche sich erschlossen.
Was machen wir denn mit Strom? Wir laden uns nicht mit Strom auf, sondern wir nutzen den für unsere Zwecke.
Ja gut, du bist aber auch kein Aal.
Wofür braucht denn Aal Strom?
Ja gut, das ist das schlechteste Beispiel.
Wofür braucht denn eine Maus Strom?
Ja Energie, dass sie da durch die Gegend läuft.
Nee.
Weil dann fängst du ja an, Roboter zu bauen. Ja gut, ich glaube, irgendwann checken Tiere das, dass sie das nutzen. Weil der Mensch kann ja auch Strom nutzen. So, dass sich dann dieses Fell aufstellt und dann ist sie irgendwie, schocken die ihre Opfer oder irgendwie sowas in der Richtung. Das können die Evolizierenden nicht vorhersagen. Ich sag einfach nur, ich werde langsam ungeduldig, weil ich will in meinem Leben noch eine Elektromaus sehen. Ich bin einfach mit Pikachu aufgewachsen und ich denke mir so, ja, das ist nicht so dumm. Aber nicht mal wir können das ja so nutzen. Die Idee ist ja, das muss doch irgendwie, aber sieht man nicht, dass Bakterien sich irgendwie nach den Magnetfeldern ausrichten oder so. Gibt es da nicht in der Mikrobiologie so Phänomene, dass die das checken, wo irgendwie dann Nord- und Südpol ist und die das irgendwie nutzen oder so. Gibt es da nicht mal ein bisschen was? Ich hatte lange einen Knoten im Kopf, Stichwort Strom. Lange habe ich darüber nachgedacht und ich kann euch jetzt nicht nur das Problem, sondern auch die Lösung präsentieren. Bin ich stolz drauf. Wie lange wird das jetzt dauern? Zwei Minuten. War ein Durchbruch für mich. Denn ich dachte die ganze Zeit, Moment, Strom ist doch eigentlich null oder eins. Entweder etwas hat Strom oder etwas hat keinen Strom. Man macht den Schalter an oder aus. Er läuft oder er läuft nicht. So, mein Handy ist noch aufgeladen, hat aber, sagen wir, nur noch fünf, sechs Prozent Akku. Und es wird langsam, es stockt. Es hat für mich nicht Sinn ergeben. Warum ist es langsamer, warum kann man es schlechter benutzen? Weil es hat ja noch Strom. Du bist ja noch bei eins. Ist ja noch aufgeladen. So, es läuft ja noch Strom durch. Warum läuft es schlechter? Und ich rede nicht von dem Stromsparmodus, sondern es läuft einfach schlechter. B, Beispiel B, Roller, ein E-Scooter in der Innenstadt. Wenn der irgendwann leer ist, leer wird, bei Leim sieht man das, dann wird diese Zitrone oben rot, wird leer, aber man hat noch theoretisch Akku, fällt er langsamer plötzlich, gibt nicht mehr so schnell Gas. Gegenbeispiel meine Apple-Kopfhörer zum Beispiel. Wenn die aufgeladen sind, die werden nie leiser. Das macht Sinn. Die hören einfach schlagartig auf. Wenn die leer sind, sind die leer. So, jetzt habe ich gedacht, okay,
0 oder 1, ihr habt herausgefunden, es ist nicht 0 oder 1.
Bestes Beispiel, dieser 9-Volt-Batterieblock.
Wenn man da am Anfang die Zunge dran macht,
an beide Noppen oben, bei diesem
9-Volt-Block, kriegt man so ein bisschen ein Gewischt.
Da ist noch viel Strom drauf.
Da schießt das richtig raus.
Wenn der leer ist, kann man den Test
machen, nämlich wie voll diese noch sind mit der Zunge. Wenn der nämlich leer leer ist, kribbelst du noch ein bisschen oder es kommt gar nichts mehr. Das heißt, man muss sich Strom, Strom fließt, wirklich wie Wasser vorstellen. Wenn richtig Wassermengen da sind, dann fließt da richtig was raus, wie am Wasserhahn. Und wenn der Tank aber langsam leer wird, dann tropft der Hahn einfach langsam aus. Das heisst, der Brunnen ist leer. Oder es ist wie eine Sanduhr, wo oben aber nicht mehr so viel drin ist und dann fließt es langsamer raus. Na gut, Sanduhr ist das gleiche, das falsche Beispiel, weil da haben wir gelernt, es fließt gleichmäßig. Aber genau, es fließt eher und wenn es nicht mehr voll ist, fließt es langsamer durch. Und dann macht es natürlich Sinn Sinn aus einer benutzerfreundlichen Perspektive,
bei Airpods zu
sagen, das macht keinen Sinn,
möglichst lang
zu funktionieren, anders als bei einem Roller, wo du ja wirklich
jeden Meter noch ausnutzen willst, also lässt er
am Ende den Strom langsamer fliessen,
lässt den Roller langsamer fahren,
wenigstens fährt er überhaupt noch, bei Kopfhörern
macht es ja nicht Sinn. Das ist ja für den Nutzer
komplett doof, wenn das einfach irgendwann leiser wird oder so, was wäre denn da die Konsequenz? Beim Handy das Gleiche. Du willst lieber, dass es später ausgeht, dafür kannst du es noch sporadisch ein bisschen nutzen, stockst es halt vielleicht ein bisschen. Das heißt, irgendwie muss es einen Begriff geben für Leute in der Technik, die sagen, lassen wir die Batterie ganz leer werden, damit am Ende die Nutzer-Experience schlechter, dafür läuft es schneller weiter. Aber es ist eine bewusste Entscheidung vom Hersteller. Genau, aber es ist eine bewusste Entscheidung vom Hersteller. Und Strom ist nicht nur nur eins, sondern Strom fließt aus wie Wasser. Okay. Das fand ich, war für mich wichtig, das herauszufinden, weil ich dachte die ganze Zeit wie, jetzt kann man nicht sagen, mein Handy hat noch Strom, wieso ist das denn so langsam und stockig? Ja. Nee, finde ich gut. Na, haben wir ein bisschen was gelernt. Haben wir mal ein bisschen was gelernt, endlich mal ein bisschen. Heute war viel Lehrreiches dabei. Heute war ein bisschen was lernen. Ihr habt was über Herr der Ringe gelernt, ihr habt was über Strom gelernt. Hast du sonst noch ein paar Titsbits für uns? Nee, sonst habe ich nichts gelernt. Ein paar kleine Titsbits. Titsbits, das darf man nicht sagen. Warum nicht? Ach so, na gut. Ich dachte, du kannst uns immer so ein paar Titsbits... Nee, das ist der Grund, warum ich Nachnamen immer auch nicht selten als Passwort benutzen darf. Du hast echt verloren einfach, vor allem Titzer aus Köln. Wenn du dich in einem amerikanischen Formular eingeben willst, vergiss es, Titt lehnt er ab und das Ü kann er auch nicht verstehen. Da hast du einen Vertrag verloren. Du bist ja auch Formel-1-Fan, haben wir letzte Woche erfahren. Da werden die ersten drei Buchstaben links in der Tabelle genutzt als Kürzel. Michael Schumacher ist MSC, aber Danny Ricardo ist RIC, Vettel ist VET, ich wäre Titt. Und das konnte ich nie eingeben in meinen Sommel-1-Spielen, weil immer gesagt wurde, nee, nimm keine Sauwörter. Vor allem, wie viele Sauwörter gibt es denn mit drei Buchstaben? Nur zwei, oder? Was ist das zweite? Sex. Ah. Mehr gibt es doch nicht, oder? Sex. Nee. Das ist wirklich wirklich Pech gehabt. Eins von den beiden. Du hast wirklich einfach Pech gehabt. Bei drei Buchstaben bist du einfach der Verlierer. Ja, gut. Das ist schwierig, aber es ist auch ein sexy Name. Also es hat auch was, glaube ich. In gewissen Kreisen, glaube ich, kann das auch ein großer Vorteil sein für dich. Ja. In der Pornobranche oder so, würdest du mit Handkuss, mit Eichelkuss, würdest du direkt aufgenommen werden. Da hast du sofort eine Chance. Ja, das stimmt eigentlich. Ja, vielleicht ist es noch eine Umschulung. Als Pornoproduzent, Darsteller ist Titz vielleicht ein bisschen merkwürdig, aber als Produzent oder so? Ja, ja, also genau, ein neuer Titz-Film, aber genau, vielleicht können wir noch so eine Umschulung machen. Kann man sich jetzt, ist ja auch ein künstlerisches Produkt, auf eine Art. Du meinst vom Arbeitsamt gefördert, eine VHS.
Was könnten Sie sich denn vorstellen?
Ja, Pornoregisseur.
Okay, wir gucken mal, sind da noch Stellen offen?
Ah ja, tatsächlich, 104 offene Stellen.
Oh, okay.
Da haben wir was in Kassel.
In Kassel.
Ja.
Ist das eine Bekannte, gibt es da was anderes, was nicht in Kassel ist?
Ist eins von den 104 nicht in Kassel? Oder alle in Kassel. Ja. Ist das eine Bekannte? Gibt es da was anderes, was nicht in Kassel ist? Ist eines von den 104 nicht in Kassel? Oder alle in Kassel? Ne, die sind alle in Kassel tatsächlich. Alle in Kassel! Kassel, da war gerade leider ein riesiges Feuer. Okay. Und deswegen brauchen die jetzt dringend 104 Pornoproduzenten. Okay, aber es war ein sehr spezifisches Feuer. Sehr, sehr spezifisch. War das die Tagung? Sehr selektives Feuer. Oder war es die Preisverleihung? Es war die Kasseler Pornoindustrie, Preisverleihung, die leider komplett niedergebrannt wurde. Lawine und niedergebrannt leider. Lawine? Lawine, ja. War direkt am Kasseler Alpen, direkt einfach Schnee rein, Schnee von unten, Feuer von oben. Okay. Und dann sind leider direkt aus dem, sind die Löschanlagen angegangen, die allerdings direkt gefroren sind, weswegen noch Eisspitzen durch den Raum geflogen sind. Und alle, die nicht vom Feuer oder vom Schnee erfasst wurden, sind dann durch diese gefrorenen Eisgeschosse dann leider umgekommen. Nee, dann würde ich doch gerne was im Controlling machen. Ja, okay, da haben wir auch einiges. Was möchten Sie denn controlen?
Irgendwie so ein boring ass.
Wir haben einiges da.
Dünger können Sie controlen.
Oder irgendwie so Fensterscheiben. Wo wenig Lawinengefahr ist.
Nicht in Kassel.
Das sieht ganz schlecht aus, leider.
Ja, alles zu Lawinengefährdet.
Hä?
Das ist ganz, ganz problematisch.
Was ist denn da los?
Das rutscht gerade alles weg. Was kommt denn da? Das rutscht... Oh, oh, oh, oh! Ah! Sie sind vielleicht doch einfach Fussballprofi. Ja, da kann man am Montag erscheinen, sie da. Fucking Lawinen, ey! Riesenproblem! Keine Angst davor. Null Angst! Ich finde Lavine Avalanche auch ein mega schönes Wort. Sehr schönes Wort. Schöner Bandname. Aber Lavine auch ein tolles Wort. Lavine. Aber ich denke mir, wäre auch ein schöner Mädchenname eigentlich, oder? Lavine? Lavine? Lavinia gibt es ja. Aber sowas wie auch Ruine oder so, so alles, was auf I erden könnte. Ruine finde ich keinen schönen Namen, nein. Ruine-Titze. Das ist unsere Tochter Ruine. Naja, also so als ... Alles, was auf i endet, könnte potenziell ein Mädchenname sein. Einfach unsere Tochter Ruine und Pampelmuse. Ruine und Lawine. Aber Ruine ist kein schöner Name. Ich glaube, man gewöhnt sich da an. Aber Ruine, Ruine, das hat doch was Schönes, Rauchiges. Ruine, kommst du mal. Ja, Baba? Ruine. Ja. Ja. Was? Ja, was? Was ist denn wieder? Ja, genau so. Ich wollte mit meiner Freundin Pampelmuse spielen. Ja, du benimmst dich wieder, wir sind richtige Ruine, weißt du das? Ruine-Titze, komm mal hierher. Das gibt es ja gar nicht. Ist doch nett. Es gibt Kinder, die heißen Wolke oder Minze. Warum denn nicht Ruine? Naja, zum einen, weil Ruine keine schöne Bild-Wort-Assoziation ergibt. Warum denn? Ich meine, das Kulisseum ist auch eine Ruine. Ja, aber es ist eher was kaputt. Es ist was kaputt. Es ist was nicht mehr so schön, wie es mal war. Das sagt Ruine aus. Ich würde gerne mal eine Lawine zweiter Ordnung sehen. Also eine Lawine und auf der Lawine entsteht eine zweite Lawine. Das gibt es, glaube ich, häufig. Und dann will ich gerne in der obersten Lawine sein. Das ist so wie, wenn ein Zug fährt und du fährst mit deinem Auto auf dem fahrenden Zug. Das finde ich, das würde ich gerne machen, so eine doppelte Bewegung. So, und dann sag mir jetzt die Geschwindigkeit. Wenn die erste Lawine mit zehn Meter pro Sekunde fährt, die andere ist nicht so ganz so schnell, nur acht Meter pro Sekunde. Wie schnell ist die auf der anderen und wie schnell bist du denn, wenn du oben drauf der zweiten Lawine fährst? Ist das eine reine Additionssache? Das sag ich dir nicht. Addition! Kommst du mal eben? Kommst du mal, bring Ruine mit. Ist alles machbar. Ja, aber vor allem da auf der noch Skifahren, auf einer Lawine Skifahren, die wiederum auf einer Lawine fährt. Sagen wir, du fährst darauf, darauf fährst du mit 12 Meter pro Sekunde.
Da bist du aber saftig schnell, knifflig schnell bist du damit. Ja, aber dann sag mir mal, wie schnell du dann insgesamt bist. Ja, du musst das addieren oder nicht? Weiß ich nicht. Ich meine, kompliziert wird es natürlich, wenn du schräg fährst auf einer Lawine, die auch wiederum schräg dann irgendwie runter geht. Wie viele Meter legst du zurück, wenn du genau im 45-Grad-Winkel fährst? Falls ihr Mathelehrer seid, gebt doch gerne mal einfach als Schulaufgabe raus, Lawine, Berg runter, zweite Lawine im 30-Grad-Winkel und der Skifahrer wiederum im 40-Grad-Winkel zu der, wie schnell fährt man insgesamt. Nee, genau. Und dann startet ihr um 18 Uhr und zwar startet ihr um 18 Uhr und fahrahrt so, genauso wie gefühlt, über die Datumsgrenze nach Osten. Die erste Lawine startet um 18 Uhr, die zweite um 18 Uhr zwei, ihr startet um 18 Uhr eins, sodass die zweite erst noch losfährt. Und ihr fahrt in Richtung Osten über die Datumsgrenze und sagt mir, wie schnell fahrt ihr in der Zeit zurück oder vor?
Ihr fahrt über die Datumsgrenze und über die amerikanische Grenze,
ab dann sind es nämlich Meilen pro Stunde.
Wie schnell seid ihr dann unterwegs?
Einfach mal Schüler quälen.
Einfach sagen, und die Schüler so,
what the, was?
Ich habe, glaube ich, sofort
ein Klutchen im Kopf, wenn es um dieses Datumgrenze geht. Ja, das ist einfach nervig. Das braucht man auch so selten im Alltag. Das stimmt, ja. Aber es muss ja Leute geben, die leben direkt auf dieser Zeitzon-Grenze. Oder die dann so einen Schritt nach rechts, plus eins, minus eins, plus eins, minus eins. Da werden noch viele Gags gemacht. Und wenn du einen Arzttermin im Nachbarort hast, dann muss doch ständig Chaos sein. Ja. Das ist unser Zeichen. Der Herr ruft. Der Herr ruft uns. Und wir geben das Zepter ab. Wir folgen dem Ruf des Herrn. Ich wünsche euch eine schöne Woche. Macht's gut! Kann man jetzt rekonstruieren, wie viel Uhr ist das? Kann man rekonstruieren, wo wir sind, weil man...
Den Doppler-Effekt?
Man kann jetzt anhand der Lautstärke und der Glockenart und der Uhrzeit genau sagen, wann und wo wir die Folge aufgenommen haben.
Dann kommt auch nächste Woche einfach gerne vorbei.
Dann nehmen wir die zusammen auf.
Ansonsten kommt gerne nach Wien, wenn ihr möchtet. Da sehen wir uns als nächstes. Bis dahin, haut rein, macht gut, wir heben ab und landen dann in Wien am nächstes, macht's gut, tschau, tschau, tschau, tschau.